I'm Jenna Fisher. And I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together. And we're best friends. And now we're doing the Ultimate Office Rewatch podcast just for you. Each week we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind the scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're The Office ladies.
我是珍娜·费舍尔。我是安吉拉·金西。我们曾一起出演过《办公室》。而且我们是最好的朋友。现在我们专门为你制作了“办公室究极重温”播客。每周我们都会剖析一集《办公室》，并分享只有当事人才能告诉你的一些独家幕后故事。我们是办公室女郎。
Hello. Hey there everybody. We have such a fun show for you today. Office, ladies. Hello. Hey there, everybody. We have such a fun show for you today. We do. We got to interview Phyllis Smith all about her time on The Office. You know, a while back when we rewatched Phyllis's wedding,
你好。大家好。今天我们为大家准备了一个非常有趣的节目。办公室女郎。你好。大家好。今天我们//@大家好。今天我们为大家准备了一个非常有趣的节目。我们确实准备了。我们采访了菲利斯·史密斯，聊了聊她当年在《办公室》的故事。你知道，前一阵子我们重温菲利斯的婚礼时，
well, Phyllis sent in some great audio clips about that episode, but we were so excited to finally have her on the podcast as a guest to do a full interview. She told us how she got her role in the office. It's such a fantastic story. I think it's maybe the best story of how someone got their job on the office. Yeah, the best origin story, yeah.
嗯，菲利斯发来了一些关于那一集的精彩音频片段，但我们非常高兴能邀请她来播客做嘉宾，进行一次完整的访谈。她告诉了我们她是如何得到《办公室》这个角色的。这是一个非常棒的故事。我觉得这可能是关于某人如何得到《办公室》工作岗位的最好的故事。是的，最佳起源故事，是的。
We also asked her all of our usual questions, you know, and Angela made sure to ask her our call sheet questions, which are now one of my favorite things of our interviews. You just find out such interesting things about people. And you know, one of the reasons I think I like it is because we know these people, and I feel like we've known them for so long, and then I learned something new. Right. And we also get to talk to Phyllis
我们还向她提出了所有常规问题，你知道的，安吉拉确保问了她我们的通告单问题，这现在已经成为我最喜欢的采访环节之一。你总是能从人们身上发现如此有趣的事情。你知道，我想我喜欢它的原因之一是因为我们认识这些人，我觉得我们认识他们很久了，然后我又学到了一些新的东西。没错。而且我们还能和菲利斯聊聊
about her new movie, Inside Out 2. It's in theaters now. My family loved the first Inside Out. We watched it so many times. I can't wait to see this one. Oh, same. My daughter has already clocked it. We have plans.
关于她的新电影《头脑特工队2》。目前正在各大影院上映。我的家人非常喜欢第一部《头脑特工队》。我们看了好多次。我等不及要看这部了。哦，我也是。我女儿已经记下上映时间了。我们已经有计划了。
We're gonna see it with her cousins. Oh, so cute. Like, it's gonna be a family event movie for us. Everybody knows the Inside Out movie's right. It's an animated movie. It's from Pixar. So in the first movie, there's a little girl, her name is Riley, and she has to move to a new city.
我们要和她的表兄弟姐妹一起去看。哦，太可爱了。对我们来说，这将是一场家庭活动电影。每个人都知道《头脑特工队》这部电影，对吧。这是一部动画电影。它来自皮克斯。所以在第一部电影里，有个小女孩，她叫莱莉，她不得不搬到一座新城市。
And in this process, we get to meet all the little emotions that are living in her head, and they are voiced by different actors, like there's Joy, that's kind of the leading emotion in her head. Joy is played by Amy Poehler, but there's also all these other emotions. There's fear, anger, disgust, there's sadness, and they kind of all come together to help Riley
在这个过程中，我们遇到了所有住在她脑海里的小情绪，它们由不同的演员配音，比如乐乐，她是她脑海里某种程度上的主导情绪。乐乐由艾米·波勒配音，但还有所有这些其他情绪。有害怕、愤怒、厌恶、悲伤，它们齐心协力帮助莱莉
with this new transition. And Phyllis plays the voice of sadness. She's so amazing in this role, and she's back playing sadness for Inside Out 2. I guess Riley is now a teenager, and she's going through puberty, which brings up a lot of new emotions. Yes. Phyllis talks to us about what is so meaningful to her
度过这个新的过渡期。而菲利斯饰演悲伤的配音。她在片中的角色太棒了，她将回归《头脑特工队2》继续为悲伤配音。我想莱莉现在是个青少年了，她正在经历青春期，这引发了许多新的情绪。是的。菲利斯跟我们聊了聊，对她而言，
about these movies, and it's just a really lovely interview. It really is. I thought that it went to some just really sweet places, and I think it's such a great representation of who Phyllis is as a person. I'm really proud of it, actually. I thought her recall of office stuff was so good. She remembers so much stuff.
这些电影有着怎样的深远意义，这真的是一次非常美好的采访。确实如此。我觉得它触及了一些非常温馨的层面，而且我认为这是对菲利斯本人真实性格的极好体现。实际上我为此感到非常骄傲。我觉得她对办公室往事的记忆力太好了。她记得好多事情。
I know. I just loved reminiscing with her. Me too. Well, you guys, why don't we take a break and when we come back, it's our interview with Phyllis. Woohoo, we made it. Woohoo! We made it! Woohoo! I was going to start out being really sad for you. Oh, you were going to be sadness to talk to you all. It's a good day.
我懂。我就是喜欢和她一起回忆过去。我也是。好了，各位，我们为什么不休息一下，等我们回来后，就是对菲利斯的采访。呜呼，我们做到了。呜呼！我们做到了！呜呼！我本来想一开始就为你感到非常难过。哦，你本来打算扮演悲伤来和大家聊天。今天是个好日子。
Oh my gosh, I love it. Phyllis, Inside Out was such a huge hit in our family, the first one. I'm so excited there's gonna be a second one and it just tickles me so much that your voice is in this movie. Oh, I'll tell ya, I'm excited to see Inside Out 2 as well. Phyllis, we watched it so many times. It's one of the movies my kids have watched over and over.
哦天哪，我太喜欢了。菲利斯，《头脑特工队》第一部在我们家里太受欢迎了。我很高兴会有第二部，而且你的声音能出现在这部电影里，让我感到非常开心。哦，我跟你说，我也很高兴能看到《头脑特工队2》。菲利斯，我们看了好多次。这是我孩子们一遍又一遍看过的电影之一。
Same. It's just so fantastic. Are your kids drawn to certain emotions more than others or just in general. In general. In general. I think they like that there's this distinction between, I mean, that's what I like about it as a parent, is that we get to see all the different emotions
我也是。简直太棒了。你的孩子们是被某些特定的情绪吸引得更多，还是总体而言。总体而言。总体而言。我想他们喜欢这种区别，我的意思也是作为父母我喜欢它的地方，就是我们能看到所有不同的情绪
and then we get to see them work together. Right. Yeah. You know how I got this part? Was one of the producers on the show couldn't sleep one night and he threw in Bad Teacher, which was Gene and Lee's movie. Yeah. That you did with Cameron Diaz. Yes. Yeah. And he couldn't sleep and he threw that DVD in.
然后我们能看到它们协同工作。没错。是的。你知道我是怎么得到这个角色的吗？是剧组的一个制片人有一天晚上睡不着觉，他放了《坏老师》，那是吉恩和李的电影。是的。就是你和卡梅隆·迪亚兹一起拍的。是的。是的。他睡不着觉，就把那张DVD放了进去。
And he immediately, when he heard my voice, he called Pete doctor and said, I found our sadness. Wow. And so, yeah, it's interesting how things just kind of go from one project to another. Had I not done bad teacher, I wouldn't have been sadness. You know? I had an acting teacher when I first was in Los Angeles who used to say, work begets work. Take the job.
当他听到我的声音时，他立刻给皮特·多克特打电话说，我找到我们的悲伤了。哇。所以，是的，这很有趣，事情就是这样从一个项目转到另一个项目的。如果我没有拍过《坏老师》，我就不会成为悲伤。你知道吗？我刚到洛杉矶时有一位表演老师，他经常说，工作带来工作。抓住机会。
Absolutely, yeah, absolutely, because you never know how it's going to connect to the next part of your life. So I was really, when I actually got the call for that movie, for Inside Out 1, I was sitting here on our sofa and the phone rang and I didn't recognize the number and I answered it. It was the casting director, the Pixar casting director, and they said, they'd like for you to come to Pixar to meet him.
绝对的，是的，绝对的，因为你永远不知道它将如何与你人生的下一部分相连。所以当我真正接到那部电影的电话时，为了《头脑特工队1》，我正坐在我们这里的沙发上，电话响了，我不认识那个号码，于是我接了。是选角导演，皮克斯的选角导演，他们说，他们想请你去皮克斯见他。
I went, okay. And so that was like in 2013 maybe. Pixar to meet him, I went, okay. So that was like in 2013 maybe. With Inside Out 1, I did about 10 different sessions in studios. All of them were in, most of them were at Disney on their studio and some up at Pixar. But unlike with Inside Out 2, because I'm not traveling, I did all of them here in St. Louis. They were kind enough to allow me to tape here in St. Louis. That's so fantastic.
我说，好的。那大概是2013年吧。皮克斯去见他，我说，好吧。对于《头脑特工队1》，我在录音室里做了大约10次不同的录音。所有这些都在，大部分在迪士尼的他们的录音室，有些在皮克斯。但与《头脑特工队2》不同的是，因为我没有到处旅行，我所有的录音都是在这里圣路易斯完成的。他们非常友善，允许我在圣路易斯录音。太棒了。
You got to make your big star demand. Right? You're like, you can have me back as sadness, but only if you come to my town this time. That's right. St. Louis, so nothing. That's probably how you said it, right? There you go. I forgot about those big star demands. Darn it. It's all too late now.
你提出了你的大明星要求。对吧？你就像是在说，你们可以让我回归饰演悲伤，但前提是这次你们得来我的小镇。没错。圣路易斯，什么都没有。你大概就是这么说的吧？就是这样。我把那些大明星的要求给忘了。该死。现在一切都太晚了。
Had you ever done voiceover work like that before, Phyllis? No. My first session was at a Disney studio and I kept looking, this is so silly, there was the music stand and there was a pencil there and I kept thinking, what do they want me to do with the pencil? Because I'd never done voiceover before. And the fact that they change it mid-sentence and you write it down. I didn't know any of that. And so I was so bothered by the pencil lying there going, what am I supposed to do with it? I know I'm supposed to do something with it. And then I found out later on in the session. But I was fortunate enough then when Amy was hired,
你以前做过这样的配音工作吗，菲利斯？没有。我的第一场录音是在迪士尼录音室，我一直看着，这太傻了，那里有一个乐谱架，上面有一支铅笔，我一直想，他们让我用铅笔做什么？因为我以前从来没有做过配音。而且他们会在句子中间进行修改，然后你要把它写下来。我对此一无所知。所以我一直被那支躺在那里的铅笔困扰着，心想，我该拿它怎么办？我知道我一定得用它做点什么。后来在录音进行到后面我才发现。但我很幸运，后来当艾米被雇佣时，
Amy and I did about maybe six sessions together. And it was kind of a on-site learning experience for me because I could watch her and learn to do it. Just on-site I did it. And so now it feels pretty comfortable and I like it. Nice. I could do more, yeah. Well, Phyllis, thank you so much for coming on Office Ladies today.
我和艾米一起大概做了六次录音。对我来说，这是一个实地学习的过程，因为我可以观察她并学习如何去做。就在现场，我就这么做了。所以现在感觉挺舒服的，我也挺喜欢。不错。我还可以做更多，是的。嗯，菲利斯，非常感谢你今天来到办公室女郎做客。
You have no idea how excited we are to get to interview you. Yeah, I was excited and also nervous for whatever reason. Oh gosh, Phyllis, you stop it. I was. It's just us gals. I know these gals. Yeah. I mean, you're the reason we have our jobs. That's right.
你根本不知道我们能有机会采访你有多兴奋。是的，我很兴奋，而且不知为什么也很紧张。哦天哪，菲利斯，别这样。我是认真的。这只是我们几个女孩。我了解这些女孩。是的。我的意思是，你就是我们有工作的原因。没错。
That's true. You know, speaking of work begets work and how you never know how one thing might come from another, will you tell our listeners how you got your job on The Office? Oh, sure. Yeah, I was the casting associate on the show. I'd been in casting about 19 years. I was working with Alison Jones, the casting director, and we were at the point in the casting process where we were pairing up the actors
确实如此。你知道，说到工作带来工作，以及你永远不知道一件事是如何由另一件事引发的，你能跟我们的听众讲讲你是如何得到《办公室》的工作的吗？哦，当然。是的，我是该剧的选角助理。我从事选角工作大约19年了。我当时和选角导演艾莉森·琼斯一起工作，我们当时正处于选角的阶段，我们要把演员们配对
to see what their chemistry would be together and putting them on tape for the producers and also for the network. Eventually it was going to go to the network. And we were in this very odd building where the actors sat at one end and the auditions were at the other end. And I remember Kim Kloppis, the director, he was getting his coffee together and he turned around to me and he said, Phyllis, I want you to read the character
看看他们在一起会产生什么样的化学反应，并将他们录下来给制片人和电视网看。最终这个项目会提交给电视网。我们在一个非常奇怪的建筑物里，演员们坐在一端，试镜在另一端。我记得导演金·克洛皮斯，他当时正在弄他的咖啡，他转过身对我说，菲利斯，我想请你今天来读一下
of Pam today. I went, what? And he said, I want you to read the character of Pam. I went, okay. Because at this point, the associate wasn't really reading with the actors. They, like I said, they were pairing the Pam and the Jims and the Dwights and everybody together. And I was a little taken back because I didn't want to step on like Alison Jones' toes. She was the boss. I didn't know if they had cleared it with her or not, but I went ahead and did it. And I was so nervous again,
帕姆这个角色。我说，什么？他说，我想让你读一下帕姆这个角色。我说，好吧。因为在那个时候，助理并不是真的和演员对词。他们，就像我说的，他们把帕姆、吉姆、德怀特和其他所有人进行配对。我有点受宠若惊，因为我不想踩到艾莉森·琼斯的脚趾。她是老板。我不知道他们是否征得她的同意，但我还是照做了。我又紧张得不行，
because I wanted to do a good job, not for me, but for the actors. I wanted to make sure that I was right there when they needed me timing-wise and such. And one of the first pair up, I was Pam and it was with Krasinski and another person who was going to audition for Dwight. And then eventually I played Dwight with two other people. And so no one ever, Greg Daniels or no one ever said to me, Phyllis, do you wanna be in the show?
因为我想把工作做好，不是为了我自己，而是为了演员们。我想确保当他们在时间把握等方面需要我时，我就在那里。在最初的配对之一中，我扮演帕姆，对方是卡辛斯基和另一个将为德怀特试镜的人。后来我又和另外两个人一起扮演了德怀特。所以从来没有人——格雷格·丹尼尔斯或其他任何人——对我说过，菲利斯，你想参演这部剧吗？
And I remember a fax came through to our office with an updated script and it had Phyllis in it. And Alison goes, is this Phyllis? And I never heard anything, you know, she goes, is this Phyllis, my Phyllis? And I never heard anything. You know, she goes, is this Phyllis, my Phyllis? But I never heard the answer. And then what happened was wardrobe called. I had one line in the pilot, wardrobe called and said, I understand you're playing the character of Phyllis. And I said, yes, I am. Because I knew from the union rules that if wardrobe called you or if you were sent a script that constitutes a work call.
我记得有一份传真发到我们办公室，上面有更新的剧本，里面出现了菲利斯这个角色。艾莉森就问，这是菲利斯吗？我从来没听到过任何消息，你知道的，她说，这是菲利斯吗，我的菲利斯？但我从来没听到答案。然后发生的事情是服装部打电话来了。我在试播集里只有一句台词，服装部打电话说，我听说你在扮演菲利斯这个角色。我说，是的，我是。因为我知道根据工会规则，如果服装部打电话给你，或者如果你被发送了剧本，那就构成了工作邀请。
And so when wardrobe called, I knew it was to be. And I said, yes. Phyllis, that is amazing. Phyllis, that is so crazy. And you know what? We know from being on a set, half the time I found out things from my character from the costume department.
所以当服装部打电话来时，我知道这是板上钉钉的事了。我说，是的。菲利斯，这太神奇了。菲利斯，这太疯狂了。你知道吗？从片场的经历中我们知道，我有一半的时间都是从服装部门得知我角色的事情的。
And it's just so wild to me that the moment you realized you had a part was because Wardrobe called you. Because Wardrobe called, yeah, exactly. And the other part of it was I was paid up on my dues. 19 years earlier, I had done one SAG job here in St. Louis, got my SAG card, and I paid my dues every year. Not because I thought I was ever,
对我来说最疯狂的是，你意识到自己有角色的那一刻，竟然是因为服装部打电话来了。因为服装部打电话来了，是的，完全如此。另一部分原因是我的会费都交齐了。19年前，我在圣路易斯做过一份演员工会的工作，拿到了工会卡，并且每年都按时交会费。不是因为我认为自己会有机会，
I had thought this ship had sailed, and it was my way of contributing to the actors. So for 19 years, I paid my dues, and I was all paid up when I got the office job then. You were ready. I was ready, yeah. Oh my gosh, so now you do the pilot and it was so crazy for us, Phyllis,
我本以为这艘船已经驶远了，这只是我支持演员的一种方式。所以在19年里，我一直交着会费，当我得到《办公室》的工作时，我的会费已经全部交清了。你准备好了。我准备好了，是的。哦天哪，所以现在你出演了试播集，对我们来说这太疯狂了，菲利斯，
because we had been reading with you, like you said, all along. And then now we walk on set and you are part of the cast. Yeah, I'll tell ya. And then now we walk on set and you are part of the cast. Yeah. I'll tell you. It was the strangest hiring in my estimation of having hired people for 19 years. But I didn't say no.
因为正如你所说，我们一直都在和你对词。而现在我们走进片场，你成了演员阵容的一部分。是的，我跟你说。而现在我们走进片场，你成了演员阵容的一部分。是的。我告诉你。以我过去19年雇人的经验来看，这是最奇怪的雇佣方式。但我没有拒绝。
I've told the story before, Phyllis, that you are responsible for me getting my very first speaking job on television because you put my tape for Spin City at the top and you told Allison I think she should get it and then I got it. And you got it. I remember meeting you too. You came in was also the one where Freaks and Geeks. Oh yeah I remember that when I came into audition for Freaks and Geeks. I didn't get it but I remember. Yeah you came in for that and I met you there. She goes Phyllis this is Jenna Fisher from St. Louis. Yeah. So and then Angela I remember when you were hired we had a different casting session because we were creating the role.
我以前讲过这个故事，菲利斯，你对我在电视上获得第一份有台词的工作负有责任，因为你把我的《城市淘金》试镜磁带放在了最上面，你告诉艾莉森我觉得她应该得到这个角色，然后我就得到了。然后你就得到了。我也记得遇见你。你来的时候也是《怪胎与书呆子》试镜的那次。哦对，我记得当我来为《怪胎与书呆子》试镜的时候。我没被选上，但我记得。是的，你为那个角色来的，我在那儿遇到了你。她说，菲利斯，这是来自圣路易斯的珍娜·费舍尔。是的。然后，安吉拉，我记得当你被录用时，我们进行了一场不同的试镜，因为我们在塑造这个角色。
Oh. And I read with you that day as well. Not only that day, but Phyllis, the very first time I went in for all the producers, just a room full of people, they had a camera on a tripod, you were reading the role of Michael when Michael fake fires Pam to impress Ryan the temp and I think it is my belief, Phyllis, and I've never really
哦。那天我也和你一起对词了。不仅那天，菲利斯，我第一次去见所有制片人的时候，满满一屋子人，他们架着一台三脚架摄像机，你在读迈克尔的角色，当时迈克尔假装解雇帕姆来给临时工瑞恩留下深刻印象，我相信，菲利斯，而且我从未真正
shared this, that the moment Pam calls Michael a jerk, right? I hit that word jerk so hard probably because I'm a little southern sometimes and feisty and the room like went quiet and your reaction was kind of wounded for a split second and I think that was the birth of Angela and Phyllis. I really do because then everyone erupted into laughter and I remember thinking in my head, oh wait, I don't think they're supposed to laugh right here. I think this is supposed to be a sad moment. It's interesting, isn't it, how your head goes through all of these exercises in a split
分享过这一点，就在帕姆叫迈克尔混蛋的那一刻，对吧？我把混蛋这个词念得非常重，可能是因为我有时带点南方人的泼辣和争强好胜，房间里突然安静了下来，你的反应有一瞬间显得有点受伤，我想那就是安吉拉和菲利斯的诞生。我真的这么认为，因为接着大家都哄堂大笑起来，我记得当时我在心里想，哦等等，我觉得他们不应该在这个地方笑。我觉得这应该是一个悲伤的时刻。很有趣，不是吗，当你在试镜的时候，你的脑海里也会在瞬间闪过所有这些排练，你知道吗？
second when you're auditioning too, you know? Yeah. It's crazy. But I was so happy to see you when they brought me back in for the accountant, you know, for this role of, they didn't even have a name for her yet. And I was like, oh, oh, that's who I read with last time. That's Phillips. Why we have a history, don't we ladies?
是的。太疯狂了。但当他们因为会计的角色——你知道，为了这个角色，甚至还没给她起名字——把我叫回去时，我很高兴看到你，当时我想，哦，哦，那是我上次一起对词的人。那是菲利斯。我们很有渊源，不是吗，女士们？
We do really do. I was just gonna tell you, Phyllis, you know, Jenna and I are rewatching the show and seeing some of these episodes for the very first time since they aired, you know, and we keep talking about characters we're falling back in love with, and Phyllis is hands down one of those characters.
我们确实很有渊源。我正想告诉你，菲利斯，你知道，珍娜和我在重温这部剧，自播出以来这是我们第一次重新看其中一些集，你知道的，我们一直在讨论那些让我们重新爱上的角色，而菲利斯绝对是其中之一。
Everything you do on this show is brilliant. Every single line you say, every look you give, it should be like an actor study class to watch you on this show. Well, thank you, I just went and tried to do the best. I don't know, I couldn't, you know, I always had my sides there hidden underneath my. In your desk drawer,
你在剧中所做的一切都太精彩了。你说的每一句台词，你给出的每一个眼神，看你在这部剧里的表现简直就像是一堂演员研习课。噢，谢谢，我只是去尽力做到最好。我不知道，我做不到，你知道的，我总是把我的剧本藏在我的。在你的办公桌抽屉里，
you would sometimes have them in that top drawer. Yeah, everybody would, you'd come and see, know my sides were there and use them too, you know. I would. I was always losing mine, but I knew where yours were. And you were welcome to use them, too. Phyllis, I have to ask you about your iconic Phyllis look. As we've been rewatching the show, we have really noticed how characters have a certain wardrobe look. And Phyllis, the character was in a lot of purple tones
你有时会把它放在那个最上面的抽屉里。是的，每个人都会，你会过来看到，知道我的剧本在那里也会顺便拿去用，你知道的。我会的。我总是弄丢我的剧本，但我知道你的放在哪儿。你也可以随便用。菲利斯，我得问问你关于你标志性的菲利斯造型。当我们重温这部剧时，我们真的注意到角色们都有某种特定的服装风格。而菲利斯这个角色穿了很多紫色色调的衣服
yes and with the big necklaces that were almost a character in and of themselves I'm curious did you have much input into this look when you met with Carrie Bennett for that first time how did this look come about? No because I was so fresh on the scene as an actor. I didn't know you could have input. So I just went, stood there, let him put the clothes on me, made silly faces as they took the pictures. I didn't want my arms to be flopping around.
是的，还有那些大项链，它们几乎本身就是一个个性格鲜明的角色。我很好奇，当你第一次见卡丽·贝内特时，你对这个造型有多少发言权？这个造型是怎么来的？没有，因为我当时作为一个演员在演艺界还是个新人。我不知道你还可以有发言权。所以我只是去那儿，站在那里，让他们把衣服套在我身上，拍照时做些傻乎乎的表情。我可不想让我的胳膊晃来晃去的。
I knew that. So I wanted my arms covered. I didn't want them to to be flopping around. I knew that. So I wanted my arms covered. I didn't want them to look like I was landing planes in the office. But that was about the only real parameter that I gave, is that I didn't want my arms to show. And the jewel tones just kind of came about, I guess, with my coloring and my eye color and stuff.
我知道这一点。所以我想要遮住胳膊。我不想让它们晃来晃去。我知道这一点。所以我想要遮住胳膊。我不想让人觉得我好像在办公室里指挥飞机降落。但这几乎是我提出的唯一的真正要求，就是我不想露出胳膊。至于那些宝石色调，我想大概是根据我的肤色、眼睛颜色之类的自然形成的。
They just started developing the different necklaces. They actually made a lot of them to make them go with the outfits. Did they really? I didn't know that. Yeah. Some of them, a lot were bought, but some were made or adjusted or two or three put together. For me, it was always interesting, we'd go in for a wardrobe fitting to see what we were actually going to be able to wear, you know, what would be in our trailers to put on because some of the outfits that we
他们开始设计各种不同的项链。实际上他们制作了许多项链来搭配这些服装。真的吗？我不知道。是的。有些是买来的，但有些是制作的、调整的，或者把两三条拼在一起。对我来说，总是很有趣的是，我们会去试衣间看看我们实际能穿什么，你知道的，我们的化妆车里会有什么衣服可以穿，因为我们
started in the beginning were there but a lot of them had changed just kind of miraculously. You would have a surprise. Yes. Well, it's funny you say that because, you know, on a lot of shows, most projects I've done, you do pick a full look and then that look ends up in your trailer. But with The Office, I felt like we were creating a closet of mix and match clothes. And so it's true. I didn't know exactly which shirt and which blouse
一开始穿的一些衣服确实在那里，但很多服装都奇迹般地换掉了。你会得到一个惊喜。是的。嗯，你这么说很有意思，因为在很多节目中，在我拍过的大多数项目中，你确实会挑选一套完整的造型，然后这套造型就会留在你的化妆车里。但对于《办公室》来说，我觉得我们是在打造一个混搭服装的衣橱。所以确实如此。我并不知道每周具体会把哪件衬衫、哪件上衣
and which cardigan were gonna be put together each week because they made a whole closet for our character and it was very mix and match. Exactly. I loved going into the costume trailer for our fittings. And if you walked in the back Every character had a whole row like a whole row of clothes So you could walk down the Dwight row of costumes and it was mostly mustard color shirts
和哪件开衫搭配在一起，因为他们为我们的角色制作了整个衣橱，而且非常适合混搭。完全正确。我非常喜欢去服装车试装。如果你走到后面，每个角色都有一整排——就像一整排的衣服。所以你可以顺着德怀特那一排服装走过去，那里基本上都是芥末黄色的衬衫。
Yeah, it was really interesting to see everyone's like row of clothes Yeah, and you could actually like you said, the character stood out by just the look. Yeah, they wouldn't even have to, yeah, they would not have to have a label. You would know. Right. You would know where Pam was and Angela and all of us. And Meredith, poor Meredith. Kate, Kate did, she had some real special outfits.
是的，看每个人的衣物排列真的很有趣。是的，而且你真的可以像你说的，光看造型就能认出那个角色。是的，甚至都不需要标签。你一眼就能认出来。没错。你会知道帕姆在哪儿，安吉拉在哪儿，还有我们所有人。还有梅雷迪思，可怜的梅雷迪思。凯特，凯特确实穿过一些非常特别的服装。
Some crazy corduroy jumpers and sweater vests. Well, you know what, Phyllis, we want to ask you a question that I always loved hearing everyone's answers is that did you have a favorite episode or scene from your time on the show or maybe a Phyllis storyline? All the above.
一些奇怪的灯芯绒连衣裤和毛衣背心。好吧，你知道吗，菲利斯，我们想问你一个问题，我一直很喜欢听大家的回答，那就是你在剧中演过的角色里，有没有哪一集或哪一个场景是你的最爱，或者有没有你最喜欢的菲利斯的故事线？以上全部。
As far as favorite episodes, there's so many that it's hard to just choose one. I agree. But there are a lot of bits and pieces from various episodes. I love the scene when Jim in Casino Night tells Pam that he's in love with her out on the parking lot. That scene always, still to this day, it makes me get a lump in my throat. And then when he comes in and sweeps her off her feet, that's even more miraculous, you know. And I love that scene. And then there's this silly scene between Dwight and Michael, where they're standing out in front of
至于最喜欢的剧集，实在太多了，很难只选出一集。我同意。但各个剧集中有很多精彩的片段和细节。我最喜欢吉姆在赌场之夜的停车场向帕姆表白的那场戏。那个场景直到今天仍然让我感到喉咙哽咽。然后当他走进来把她抱起来时，那就更奇妙了，你知道的。我太喜欢那个场面了。还有德怀特和迈克尔之间那个滑稽的场景，他们站在
Andy Buckley's character's house. They thought that they were the ones that kept the office from closing. Yes. Yes. They high-fived and then the one says to the other, I don't know, how did we do it? I don't know. I don't know what how did we do it? I don't know. I don't know what we did, but we did it, you know?
安迪·巴克利饰演的角色的房子外面。他们以为是他们阻止了办公室倒闭。是的。是的。他们击掌，然后一个人对另一个人说，我不知道，我们是怎么做到的？我不知道。我不知道我们是怎么做到的？我不知道。我不知道我们做了什么，但我们确实做到了，你知道吗？
And it's such a stupid little scene. And for some reason it always stuck out in my mind too, you know? And then there's close your mouth, sweetie. You look like a trout. And then Angela, we had our whole Christmas where we just, when you put that hair net on and, when you put that hair net on, and I mean, you put your hair net on. Yeah. That whole episode was pretty special. Phyllis, my kids lost their minds when they watched the scene between you and I, where I come up to you and I like, I'm like, Phyllis, these are forks. Like that scene, they couldn't get over it. Yes, when you're explaining everything.
这是一个非常愚蠢的小场景。不知为什么它也总是深深地印在我的脑海里，你知道吗？然后还有“闭上嘴，甜心。你看起来就像一条鳟鱼。”还有安吉拉，我们有一整段圣诞情节，当你戴上那个发网的时候，当你戴上那个发网的时候，我是说，你戴上了发网。是的，那一集相当特别。菲利斯，当我的孩子们看到你和我之间的那个场景时，他们简直惊呆了，我走到你面前说，菲利斯，这些是叉子。就像那个场景，他们简直无法释怀。是的，当你把一切都解释清楚的时候。
They'll say to me in the kitchen sometimes, Mom, this is a fork. I'm like, okay, ha ha. Yeah, we had some really great scenes, didn't we? We did. One of my favorite storylines, Phyllis, is when we find out that you do not like the office administrator over advanced refrigeration.
他们有时会在厨房对我说，妈妈，这是一把叉子。我就说，好吧，哈哈。是的，我们有一些非常棒的场景，不是吗？确实如此。我最喜欢的故事线之一，菲利斯，就是我们发现你讨厌先进冷藏公司的那位办公室行政人员。
Yes. Oh, yes. You do not care for her. Because she looks pretty much like me, first off. Younger, though. Yes. She looks pretty much like me, you know, first off. Younger though. Yes, and Pam sees this woman as kind of a mentor and that is a storyline I wanted to see more of. I really, really, I could have watched that
哦，是的。哦，是的。你一点也不喜欢她。因为首先她长得跟我挺像的。不过更年轻一点。是的。首先她长得跟我挺像的，你知道的。不过更年轻。是的，帕姆把这个女人看作是一种导师，这也是一条我想看到更多发展的故事线。我真的、真的，我可以看好几集
for multiple episodes. I guess maybe I put a wise word into Bob or something cause she didn't come back. She did not. That's right. I put a wise word into Bob or something because she didn't come back. She did not. That's right. I tell you, the one scene I had a really hard time not laughing through was when Steve and I at my wedding.
关于这个内容。我想也许我跟鲍勃或者谁吹了点枕边风，所以她就没再回来了。她确实没再回来。没错。我跟鲍勃或者谁吹了枕边风，所以她没再回来了。她确实没再回来。没错。我跟你说，我最难忍住不笑的一场戏，就是史蒂夫和我拍我婚礼的那场。
Oh gosh. When he came into the bride's room to give me advice and we could not get through the word pungent because I had let it toot yeah and every time he would say pungent he would break out in his cackle he couldn't he couldn't get through it and I couldn't get through it and then we hear the sound people sitting outside the door laughing. So they had to move them down the stairway, down into the bottom because every time we said pungent, we lost it. I finally, the only way I got through was to hold my breath.
哦天哪。当他走进新娘休息室给我提建议时，我们怎么也念不过“刺鼻”这个词，因为我刚才放了个屁，是的，每当他说“刺鼻”这个词时，他就会发出格格的笑声，他根本过不去这道坎，我也过不去，然后我们听到音响师坐在门外笑。所以他们不得不把他们赶下楼梯，赶到下面去，因为每次我们说到“刺鼻”时，我们就彻底破功了。我最后能撑过去唯一的方法就是屏住呼吸。
When he said pungent, I just held my breath into the end of the scene. So if I'd looked a little blue in that scene, that's the reason. I also noticed you look down like at your feet, like you were like, I cannot make eye contact with this man right now. Yeah. Phyllis, is there a moment from our time on The Office, it could be anything, you know,
当他说“刺鼻”时，我就一直屏住呼吸直到这场戏结束。所以在那个场景里如果我看起来有点发青，那就是原因所在。我还注意到你向下看自己的脚，就像是在说，我现在绝对不能跟这个男人有任何眼神接触。是的。菲利斯，在我们一起拍《办公室》的时光里，有没有哪个瞬间——不管是什么，你知道的，
on set or off set, if you could go back and relive a moment, if you could go sit in that moment again, what would you like to do? I would like to redo when we won the Emmy, when we all ran up on stage, we were told we shouldn't go, we had to stay in the audience, we weren't allowed to go up. It was a long shot that we were gonna win and when we did win, we all just ran to the stage
片场内还是片场外，如果你能回到过去重温某个瞬间，如果你能再次回到那一刻，你想做什么？我想重新经历我们赢得艾美奖的那一次，当我们所有人跑上舞台时，他们告诉我们不应该上去，我们必须留在观众席，不允许上去。我们能获奖的几率微乎其微，但当我们真的获奖时，我们都朝舞台跑去
and I loved the joy that everybody had, cause that was our Emmy, that we won. So I loved that moment for that reason. And then Angela, were you in the boat with me when we went back? Yes, Phyllis. Yeah. But only people only remember that it was you on the boat. Like Jenna's memory was like, remember when Phyllis got lost at sea and I was like, hello.
我喜欢每个人脸上的喜悦，因为那是属于我们的艾美奖，是我们赢得的。所以我喜欢那个时刻，原因就在于此。然后安吉拉，我们回去的时候你在那条船上吗？是的，菲利斯。是的。但大家只记得你在船上。就像珍娜的记忆是这样的，还记得菲利斯在海上迷路的那次吗，然后我说，哈喽。
I was on the boat too with rain and Brian. You have Brian, you, me, the wardrobe lady and rain and rain and that was a very memorable night. We were stranded out there in the middle of the ocean. Pitch darkness just drifting out to sea. pitch darkness just drifting out to sea. And then they wanted us to transfer boats. Oh, Phyllis. To stand up and actually go to the other boat was frightening because they were holding it with their foot. Yes, this is the thing.
我也在船上，还有雷恩和布莱恩。当时有布莱恩、你、我、服装大姐，还有雷恩，那是一个非常难忘的夜晚。我们被困在海洋正中央。一片漆黑，任由船只漂向大海。一片漆黑，任由小船随波逐流。然后他们想让我们换乘小船。哦，菲利斯。站起来并真正换到另一艘船上真的很吓人，因为他们是用脚夹住船来固定的。是的，就是这样。
I tried to explain this in our book that Jen and I wrote, and I really don't think I did it justice because these two rubber dinghies were being held together by just one man like straddling them. You know, we're trying to climb over. And we're going, what? Yeah. And it's bobbing up and down. And I'm like, how are we doing this? Once we got back to shore, it seemed OK. But in the middle of it, it was pretty frightening.
我试图在我们俩合著的书里解释这一点，但我觉得我写得还不够贴切，因为这两艘橡胶小艇仅仅靠一个男人叉开腿跨在它们中间来固定。你知道的，我们正试着爬过去。我们当时在想，什么？是的。而且它还在上下颠簸。我当时想，我们怎么做到的？一旦回到岸上，感觉还好。但在过程中，确实挺吓人的。
Yeah. We also love to ask everyone what they took from set when we wrapped, because Jen and I took a lot of things. Let's see. I took the bird that Stanley carved for me when he was down in Florida. I have that. I wanted my bushiest beaver award, but it seemed to have gotten lost somewhere along the side. What? Phyllis, you need the bushiest beaver award in your home.
是的。我们还喜欢问每个人杀青时从片场顺走了什么东西，因为珍娜和我拿了很多东西。让我想想。我拿了斯坦利在佛罗里达时为我雕刻的那只鸟。我有那个。我本来想要我的“毛发最浓密的海狸奖”，但它好像不知怎么在半路上弄丢了。什么？菲利斯，你家里必须得有一个“毛发最浓密的海狸奖”。
On the wall. Yeah, I need that. And I would have liked to have had the oven mitt, but I don't remember getting that either that I made for Michael. Oh, yeah. That scene was hilarious. Talk about brilliant performance by you when Michael hates the Muffin Mits so much. Oh Phyllis. Yeah, we had some great times, didn't we ladies? We did. We really did. It's been such a joy to go back and rewatch because it just opens the floodgates of memories. We did a lot of weird, funny, good, odd things in our nine years. We did. You know, Phil, is one of the things Jen and I love is that we get the call sheets from Steve Burgess and on the back of them are these cast and crew questions where they
挂在墙上。对，我需要那个。而且我本想要那个烤箱隔热手套，但我不记得我有拿到那个我为迈克尔做的手套了。哦，是的。那个场景太滑稽了。说到你精彩绝伦的表演，当时迈克尔极其讨厌那个松饼隔热手套。哦，菲利斯。是的，我们有过很多美好的时光，不是吗，女士们？我们确实有。真的有过。回过头来重温这一切简直是一种享受，因为它一下子打开了记忆的闸门。在我们合作的九年里，我们做过很多古怪、有趣、美好、奇特的事情。确实如此。你知道吗，菲利斯，珍娜和我最喜欢的一点就是我们从史蒂夫·伯吉斯那里拿到了通告单，在通告单的背面有这些演职人员问答，他们
would pick a member of the cast and crew and ask them five questions. And so we would love to ask you the call sheet questions. I just have delighted in them. Are you ready? Okay. All right. Here's a good one. Number one, what was your first entertainment job? Oh, my first entertainment job was dancing. I got paid a dollar at the Carpenter's Hall here in St. Louis on Hampton Avenue. And I did a toe dance to a doll coming out of a doll box. I got paid a dollar. How old were you? I was at point so I was about eight years old. Wow.
会挑选一名演员或剧组成员并问他们五个问题。所以我们也想问你通告单上的问题。我一直觉得这些问题太美妙了。你准备好了吗？好的。好嘞。这有个好问题。第一，你的第一份娱乐行业的工作是什么？哦，我的第一份娱乐行业的工作是跳舞。我在圣路易斯汉普顿大道的木匠大厅赚了一美元。我伴随着一个洋娃娃从洋娃娃盒子里跳出来的音乐跳了一段足尖舞。我赚了一美元。你当时多大？我正处于足尖舞阶段，所以大概八岁吧。哇。
That was my first job, and I still have the dollar. Do you really? You do? I do. I folded it up and put it in the picture of that particular dance, yeah. I would love to see that. You were dancing on Pointe at eight years old, Phyllis? Yeah, I started dancing at seven, and she put me on Pointe. I can see that. You were dancing on point at eight years old, Phyllis?
那是我的第一份工作，我到现在还留着那一美元呢。真的吗？你真的留着？留着呢。我把它折好夹在那次特定舞蹈的照片里了，真的。我很想看看。你八岁就能跳足尖舞了，菲利斯？是的，我七岁开始跳舞，她就让我穿上足尖鞋了。我能看出来。你八岁的时候就能踩着足尖鞋跳舞了，菲利斯？
Yeah, I started dancing at seven and she put me on point. I was just about eight, probably going into nine, like closer to nine. But I was about eight years old when she put me on point. Yeah. I mean, this is something that I think our listeners know about you, but we should remind you that you are a phenomenal dancer
是的，我七岁开始跳舞，她就让我穿上足尖鞋了。我差不多八岁，可能快九岁了，更接近九岁吧。但我大概八岁的时候她就让我穿足尖鞋了。是的。我的意思是，我想我们的听众对你很了解，但我们应该提醒大家，你是一位杰出的舞者
that you danced for a long time. I did. I danced till I was in my, I would say 32 or so professionally and then it got to the point it was, you know, hard to compete with the 18 year olds. But yeah, I danced, I did it all. I did ballet, I was in two ballet companies. I was in a jazz company in San Diego, the jazz company. I toured it when Dinner Theater was around. I was in a Vaudeville Burlesque show for, we toured about six, seven years. And then I was in another show in Long Beach, California, where we performed three shows Saturday, three shows Sunday.
你跳了很长时间的舞。是的。我一直跳到大概32岁左右，作为专业舞者，然后到了那个阶段，你知道的，很难跟18岁的年轻人竞争了。所以是的，我跳舞，我什么都跳。我跳芭蕾，我在两个芭蕾舞团待过。我在圣地亚哥的一个爵士舞团待过，那个爵士舞团。晚餐剧院盛行的时候我曾随团巡演。我在一个滑稽歌舞杂耍秀里演过，我们巡演了大约六、七年。后来我在加利福尼亚州长滩的另一个演出里表演，我们在那里每周六演三场，周日演三场。
Wow. But we got paid enough to for the whole week. So it was pretty lucrative, you know, it was okay. So yeah, my career started out as a dancer. Then when I got too old and injured, then I ended up going into casting. Can I tell you that story? Yes, please. I was working at an aerospace defense company as the receptionist. A friend of mine called and said, Phyllis, they want a mousy woman. It was for a court show and they wanted a mousy woman. So I had a half an hour to get over the hill in LA,
哇。但我们赚的钱够全周花的。所以收益相当不错，还行吧。所以，是的，我的职业生涯是从舞者开始的。后来当我年纪大了而且受伤了，我就转行做了选角。我能跟你讲讲那个故事吗？好的，请讲。我当时在一家航空航天防务公司当接待员。我的一个朋友打电话说，菲利斯，他们想要一个畏缩不前的女人。那是一个法庭节目，他们需要一个畏缩不前的女人。所以我只有半小时的时间越过洛杉矶的山，
to go from the valley to Hollywood and back. I was in the bathroom and we wore nylons at those times, lady, pantyhose. I know all about pantyhose, Phyllis. I wore them for nine years on the office. You guys both wore pantyhose on the office. I did not. Yes. And when I went in there before to go to this audition, I not only tore a run in my neck, my whole hand went through right below the knee. So there was this huge hole, but my dress was long
从山谷赶到好莱坞再返回。我当时在洗手间里，那个年代我们穿尼龙袜，女士们，连裤袜。我对连裤袜太了解了，菲利斯。我在《办公室》里穿了九年。你们在《办公室》里都穿了连裤袜。我没有。是的。当我之前进去准备这次试镜时，我不但在脖子那里扯破了一个抽丝，我的整只手直接从膝盖下方穿了过去。所以那里有一个巨大的洞，但我的裙子足够
enough that it covered it. So when I went into the audition, I said to the lady, excuse me, were you looking for a mousy woman or a tacky woman? And I lifted up my skirt and shoulder, my knee, and she laughed. And then in the course of that audition, I said, you know, I think I might be good in casting. About two weeks later, she called me and that's how I got into casting and was in it for 19 years, working different levels, you know, working your way up. But it all stemmed from a weird audition for a mousy woman.
长，刚好把它盖住了。所以当我走进试镜间时，我对那位女士说，对不起，请问你们是在找一个畏缩不前的女人，还是在找一个俗气的女人？然后我掀起裙子指了指我的膝盖，她笑了。然后在试镜的过程中，我说，你知道，我觉得我可能很适合做选角。大约两周后她打电话给我，这就是我进入选角行业并干了19年的经过，从不同的层级做起，你知道的，一步步往上爬。但这一切都源于一次为找一个畏缩不前的女人的奇怪试镜。
From a run in your pantyhose, really bonded y'all. And they said I wasn't mousy enough. So I said, OK. Phyllis, do you think you'll perform at the Muny again? How many shows have you done there? Three? No, I've just done two. I did Nonsense and you know what I did, Jenna. I can't remember.
从你连裤袜上的一个抽丝开始，你们真的结下了不解之缘。他们说我还不够畏缩。所以我说，好吧。菲利斯，你觉得你还会再去曼伊露天剧场表演吗？你在那里演过多少部剧了？三部？没有，我只演过两部。我演过《无稽之谈》，你知道我演的另一部是什么吗，珍娜。我想不起来了。
I remembered Nonsense, but I can't remember the other show. Oh, oh, oh, it's on the tip of my tongue. Yeah. Yes, yes, I know. Why can't we the other show. Oh, oh, oh, it's on the tip of my tongue. Yeah. Yes, yes, I know. Why can't we think of it? John and John Travolta, they're there. Grease? Yes, yes.
我记得《无稽之谈》，但我想不起来另一部是什么剧了。哦，哦，哦，它就在我嘴边。是的。是的，是的，我知道。我们怎么就想不起另一部剧了呢？约翰和约翰·特拉沃尔塔，他们也在那儿。油脂？是的，是的。
Yes, that's right, yes. Yes. Do you guys wanna share with everyone what the Muni is for our listeners who might not know? It's a 12,000 seat outdoor theater here in St. Louis. They do their own shows here in St. Louis and they also bring in shows from New York and various. Oh, like traveling shows.
是的，没错，是的。你们想不想跟所有听众分享一下曼伊剧场是什么，对于那些可能不知道的听众来说？那是圣路易斯的一个拥有12,000个座位的露天剧场。他们在这里上演自己的剧目，也会把来自纽约和各地的剧目引进过来。哦，就像巡演剧目一样？
Yeah, you know, the Muni is where I was really introduced to live musical theater. My mom would take me and like you said, it's 12,000 seats and we could only afford seats kind of way in the back. You would rent binoculars. And so you would watch these performances through binoculars, but the sound in this outdoor amphitheater, it was just,
对，你知道的，曼伊剧场是我真正接触到现场音乐剧的地方。我妈妈会带我去，就像你说的，那里有12,000个座位，我们只能买得起最后排的座位。你会租一副望远镜。所以你是通过望远镜观看这些演出的，但在这个露天剧场里的音响效果，简直是，
and it would be like a warm summer night in St. Louis. You wait for the sun to go down, right? You wait for it to get dark and then the show starts. And my gosh, just some joyous moments from my childhood going to the Muni to see shows. So it's really meaningful for like a St. Louis person to then get to star in a show there, I'm sure. Absolutely. I was taken back when I first walked on that stage from the stage side of it and looking out to those 12,000 seats. It was really, you know, gave me another lump in your throat because it's pretty spectacular. Remember Jenna, they would turn the big fans on during the intermission?
而且那会是圣路易斯一个温暖的夏夜。你等着太阳落山，对吧？你等着天黑下来，然后演出就开始了。哦天哪，我童年时去曼伊剧场看演出，有着太多欢乐的时刻。所以对于一个圣路易斯人来说，能有机会在那里主演一部剧，意义一定非凡，我敢肯定。绝对是的。当我第一次从舞台一侧走上那个舞台，望向那12,000个座位时，我惊呆了。这真的，你知道的，让我再次感到喉咙哽咽，因为那实在太壮观了。还记得吗，珍娜，中场休息时他们会打开巨大的电风扇？
Yeah. Because like in August, it could get pretty hot there. You know? Yeah. Well, now they've improved the fans. They can leave them on the whole time. Oh, and they're not too loud? They're not loud at all. Oh, wow.
对。因为就像在八月，那里会变得非常热，你知道吗？是的，现在他们把风扇改进了。他们可以一直开着。哦，而且声音不会太大吗？一点也不吵。哦，哇。
That's a big plus to go to the mix. It sure is. It sure is. It's the little things that count. I love these St. Louis gals. Question number two. Do you play a musical instrument? I played a musical instrument. I played a clarinet.
这去混合剧场真是一大加分项。确实是的。确实是的。细节决定成败。我太喜欢这些圣路易斯女孩了。第二个问题。你会演奏乐器吗？我演奏过乐器。我拉过单簧管。
I was in the marching band and also the orchestra in high school. Wow. And I was second chair. Wow. It wasn't the first chair, but I played second chair. That's pretty dang good, Phyllis, second chair. Well, I don't know how good I was, but I started out with the flute and I couldn't get a sound out of it.
我在高中时加入了行进乐队和管弦乐队。哇。我是第二首席。哇。虽然不是第一首席，但我拉的是第二首席。这已经相当不错了，菲利斯，第二首席。嗯，我不知道我拉得有多好，但我一开始学的是长笛，却怎么也吹不出声音。
So I said, please take me off the flute. I cannot do this. And so he gave me a clarinet and I went, okay, I'll try. So you guys play instruments? Well, when I moved to Archer went, okay, I'll try. So you guys play instruments? Well, when I moved to Archer City, Texas, the school, you know, they really needed everyone to participate in the band or we wouldn't have had one because my school was so small. We were class size 2A. So I graduated with like 34 people.
所以我说，请让我别学长笛了。我真的做不到。于是他给了我一支单簧管，我说，好吧，我试试。所以你们会演奏乐器吗？当我搬到得克萨斯州阿彻城时，学校，你知道的，真的很需要每个人都参加乐队，否则我们就组建不起来，因为我的学校太小了。我们是2A级学校。所以我和大约34个人一起毕业。
So they needed everyone in the band. So football players on the football team, cheerleaders, they marched in the marching band in their uniforms. Like they, you know, everyone participated. So they pretty much told me, you're gonna be in band. And I was like, guys, I don't play an instrument, like at all. And they were like, you know what, we really need some trombone players. I was like, what? I am four feet eight. And they gave me a trombone and I played it with my friend Shannon. It was me and Shannon and this kid named Bill. There was three of us and I was second chair,
所以他们需要每个人都加入乐队。因此足球队的队员、啦啦队员，他们都穿着制服加入行进乐队。就像他们，你知道的，每个人都参与其中。所以他们基本上告诉我，你得进乐队。当时我就想，伙计们，我根本不会任何乐器。然后他们说，你知道吗，我们真的很需要几个长号手。我当时想，什么？我身高只有四尺八寸。他们给了我一把长号，我和我的朋友香农一起吹。当时就我和香农，还有一个叫比尔的孩子。我们一共三个人，我是第二首席，
but only because there were three of us. I wanna see that. Oh my gosh, Phyllis, I couldn't even reach seventh position on the trombone. I just had to let it slide out because I couldn't reach it. It's funny. And what about you, Jenna?
但那只是因为我们总共才三个人。我很想看看那个。哦天哪，菲利斯，我甚至都够不到长号的第七把位。我只能让它滑出去，因为我胳膊不够长。太搞笑了。那你呢，珍娜？
Growing up, my mom had us play piano. But this was really because I think my mom really regretted in her life that she didn't play a musical instrument and she wanted to play piano. So we got a piano and she hired a teacher and she took lessons, I took lessons and my sister took lessons. And I mean, I don't play the piano. It didn't stick. I think because I wasn't really interested in playing the piano. But then as an adult, I did a movie, Walk Hard, and I was gifted at the beginning of the movie a really nice acoustic guitar. And I got very interested in playing and I was really picking it up.
我从小我妈妈就让我们学钢琴。但其实这主要是因为我觉得我妈妈人生中最大的遗憾就是没有学会一门乐器，她自己很想弹钢琴。所以我们买了一架钢琴，她请了一位老师，她上课，我和我姐姐也上课。我的意思是，我并不会弹钢琴。我没坚持下来。我想是因为我对弹钢琴其实没那么感兴趣。但后来成年后，我拍了一部电影《永不止步》，在电影开拍时我收到了一把非常不错的木吉他作为礼物。我对弹吉他变得非常感兴趣，而且学得很快。
I got really into it. You know, so much so that Angela has a funny story. When we traveled to New York together, I took the guitar with me. I carried it on the plane. Like a backpack. We went through the airport with this thing. It was so cumbersome. Like when we went to the bathroom,
我真的迷上了。以至于安吉拉有一个有趣的故事。当我们一起去纽约时，我把吉他带上了。我把它背在飞机上。像个背包一样。我们背着这东西穿过机场。太笨重了。比如我们去洗手间时，
I'd have to hold her backpack. My guitar. Your guitar backpack. Yeah. You were very committed to it. I really believed that I was gonna become a later in life guitar player. But then, Phyllis, I don't know if you remember
我都得拿着她的背包。我的吉他。你的吉他背包。是的。你对它太执着了。我当时真的坚信自己会成为一个大器晚成的吉他手。但后来，菲利斯，我不知道你还记不记得
when I fell down the stairs at the up front. Well, not only did I fracture my back in four places, but I hurt my elbow. It landed on the stairs and I like bruised my elbow bone. And as a result, I couldn't practice the guitar anymore. It was really painful. And by the time I healed, I had kind of, you'd let it go. I had to let it go. I can, it was like one of those things where it was like, well, I mean, I guess I didn't love the guitar so much that I wanted to, you know, yeah, play through the pain. But I, I, yeah, those are my stories. I fiddled with piano and I filled with guitar, but ultimately I never really played an instrument. Well, guess what?
当我从发布会现场的楼梯上摔下来的时候。嗯，我不但脊椎骨折了四个地方，还伤了胳膊肘。我直接摔在楼梯上，我的手肘骨头都摔青了。结果，我再也不能练习弹吉他了。真的很疼。等我伤势痊愈时，我已经有点，你放弃了。我只能放弃了。我能，这就好像是一种情况，那就是，好吧，我的意思是我大概并没有那么热爱吉他，以至于我想要，你知道的，忍痛坚持下去。但我，是的，这就是我的故事。我瞎折腾过钢琴，也瞎折腾过吉他，但最终我确实没有真正学会任何乐器。好吧，你猜怎么着？
I'm not playing the trombone anymore. And I'm not playing the piano anymore. Yeah. Okay, next question. What's a place that you've been to that you absolutely loved? Oh, well, I haven't been to that many places, but I did go to Cannes. Oh, in France?
我也不再吹长号了。我也不再弹钢琴了。好吧，下一个问题。你去过哪个地方是你绝对热爱的？哦，好吧，其实我没去过太多地方，但我去过戛纳。哦，在法国？
Mm-hmm. And it was quite spectacular. It was for Inside Out 1, for the film festival there, And it was just incredibly beautiful. We did an interview out on a dock. It's hard to be interviewed when you're so mesmerized by the beautiful ships. And the yachts were unbelievable, of the billionaires. Oh, wow. There it was.
嗯。那里相当壮观。那是为了《头脑特工队1》去那里的电影节，而且真的美得难以置信。我们在码头上做了一个采访。当你被那些美丽的船只深深迷住时，采访其实很难进行。那些亿万富翁的游艇简直不可思议，哦，哇。就在那儿。
It was incredible. The people would say, I'd say, you sure that's not a cruise ship? They go, no, that's just a little yacht that belongs to somebody. Are they just so big? I don't think I've, I've never seen a yacht up close. They're incredibly big, huge. I mean, they're like, I don't know how many stories. Wow. It's not anything that we see here in the United States truly it isn't you know, yeah Yeah, but that made a big impression on me the can did can France
太不可思议了。人们会说，我会问，你们确定那不是游轮吗？他们会说，不，那只是属于某人的小小游艇。它们是不是太大了？我想我没有，我从没见过这么近距离的游艇。它们大得难以置信，巨大无比。我的意思是，它们就像是，我不知道有多少层楼高。哇。这真不是我们在美国能见到的景象，确实不是，你知道的，是的。但戛纳给我留下了深刻的印象，戛纳，法国。
Yeah, also their butter and their fruit in France was amazing The butter their strawberries actually tastes like strawberries. It's the little things in life, you know? Yeah, I love butter with the chunky salt in it. I had that in France and I thought this has changed my life. No, it's true. You think of the French with their baguettes and their bread, but I think their secret is the butter. It actually tastes so creamy. It has so much cream in it. I'm getting hungry. Don't get me started on butter. Okay, next question. What do you like to do on the weekends? Oh, well, it depends on where I am, you know, where I'm located and what I'm doing. Like when I was working, I like to stay home. You know, when we were working every, you know, Monday through Friday, I would like to stay at my house
还有，他们在法国的黄油和水果太棒了。他们的黄油，草莓吃起来真的像草莓。这就是生活中的小确幸，你知道的？是的，我喜欢带大颗粒盐的黄油。我在法国吃过那个，当时觉得这改变了我的人生。不，真的。你以为法国人只有法式长棍面包，但我认为他们的秘诀其实是黄油。吃起来真的很细腻顺滑。里面含有超多奶油。我开始饿了。别跟我聊黄油了。好吧，下一个问题。你周末喜欢做些什么？哦，好吧，这取决于我在哪里，你知道的，我在什么地方以及在做什么。就像我工作的时候，我喜欢呆在家里。你知道的，当我们周一到周五每天都在工作时，我喜欢待在家里
and enjoy the backyard and everything. Oh, I love spending time in the backyard. Last question, what is your favorite midnight snack? Oh, gosh, I like nachos and a Pepsi. I like to put cheddar cheese on nachos and a Pepsi. I love that. I love it. Well, Phyllis, before you go, can we just ask you a little bit again about Inside Out 2 and what can we expect from the story this time? Well, as we know, our girl is going through puberty. She's starting puberty. So her emotions have expanded, let's say. Oh, yeah.
享受后院和一切。哦，我太喜欢在后院度过时光了。最后一个问题，你最喜欢的深夜零食是什么？哦，天哪，我喜欢玉米片配百事可乐。我喜欢在玉米片上放切达奶酪，再配上一杯百事可乐。我太喜欢了。我超爱。好吧，菲利斯，在你离开之前，我们能再稍微问你一点关于《头脑特工队2》的事吗，这次我们对这个故事有什么期待？嗯，如我们所知，我们的女孩正在经历青春期。她开始进入青春期了。所以她的情绪扩展了，可以这么说。哦，是的。
I think her original emotions are all taken back by all the other ones that surface. And I'm really looking forward to it because, as I said, I did a lot of my recordings singularly here. I'm anxious to see how we all fit together in her mind because there are, golly, I think about four or five new emotions joining the crowd. Oh, I can't wait. We have anxiety and embarrassment, who I have a kinship to. Sadness and embarrassment seem to play along the same lines.
我想她原本的情绪都被所有这些新浮现的情绪给惊到了。我真的很期待，因为正如我所说，我的很多录音都是在这里单独完成的。我很急切地想看看我们如何在她的脑海里完美融合，因为，天哪，我想大概有四五种新情绪加入了这个大家庭。哦，我等不及了。我们有焦虑和尴尬，我对后者很有共鸣。悲伤和尴尬似乎有着相似的特质。
And envy, anxiety, and another odd little character. So we shall see how they all play together. I know all sadness wants to do is to keep Riley safe in all of this turmoil. And so she goes on a mission far away from the other emotions to try and help this situation. I don't want to get too much away. Sure. Yeah. I think it's going to be really interesting and it's going to help people. I don't know, like you were saying, your children enjoyed watching the movie multiple times. I know through the years, people have come up to me and said, you know, I really enjoyed the movie. It helped my daughter get through this period of her life. She was going through a great deal of sadness
还有嫉妒、焦虑以及另一个奇怪的小角色。所以我们将拭目以待它们将如何共同发挥作用。我知道所有悲伤想做的就是在这一切的混乱中保护莱莉的安全。所以她踏上了一段远离其他情绪的旅程，试图帮助解决这个局面。我不想剧透太多。当然。是的。我认为这会非常有趣，而且它会帮助到人们。我不知道，就像你说的，你的孩子们很喜欢多次观看这部电影。我知道多年来，人们走过来对我说，你知道，我真的很喜欢这部电影。它帮助我的女儿度过了她人生中的这段时期。她当时正经历着巨大的悲伤
and she found out that it's okay to be sad. Yeah. A lot of teachers tell me that they have programs in schools now where they actually use the five emotions. So now they're going gonna have to get new programs and add some other emotions to it. So it comes out June the 14th, I believe. So I can't wait.
然后她发现原来感到悲伤是没有问题的。是的。许多老师告诉我，他们现在学校里的项目里实际上会用到这五种情绪。所以现在他们不得不开发新的项目并加入一些其他的情绪了。所以它将于6月14日上映，我想是的。所以我等不及了。
I think it's gonna be another good one. As a mother of three teenagers, I can't wait because it just makes it all so relatable. I was gonna say, you're gonna feel at home with it probably. Well, the first movie was also just so fun and funny, but also so layered with this, just the naming of the emotions and seeing them work together
我觉得这又会是一部佳作。作为三个青少年的母亲，我等不及了，因为它让一切都变得那么感同身受。我正想说，你可能会对它感到非常亲切。嗯，第一部电影不仅有趣又好笑，而且还富有层次，通过给情绪命名并看到它们协同工作，
and that like, you don't have to get rid of any emotion that can all exist and that they're all there to serve you. I just think that's what's so beautiful about the movie. Right. I know that part two will have those similar things. I'm excited. Jen and I will be watching it. We will.
并且传达出——你不必摆脱任何情绪，它们可以全部共存，而且它们的存在都是为了服务于你。我觉这正是这部电影最美妙的地方。没错。我知道第二部分也会有这些相似的元素。我很兴奋。珍娜和我会去看的。我们一定会看的。
Definitely many times with our kids. These movies are a true gift and I will be watching it. We will. Definitely many times with our kids. These movies are a true gift, and I think they open up such dialogue about emotions like Jenna was saying. And we're so happy to see you, Phyllis, and to have you here. Yes. I hope I did OK for you guys. I hope you did.
肯定会陪着孩子们看好多次。这些电影是真正的馈赠，我觉得它们引发了关于情绪的深刻对话，就像珍娜刚才所说的那样。我们很高兴见到你，菲利斯，也很高兴你能来。是的。希望我刚才表现得还不错。希望你们满意。
Yes. You crushed it, Phyllis. You crushed it. Is there anything that you would want to share that we didn't get to cover? No, I think we covered a lot. I mean, there were other, when we got talking about The Office, I was thinking, not because they were your episodes, but I loved, I truly loved both your weddings. They all had their own just hilarious and heartfelt moments in each of them, you
是的。你表现太棒了，菲利斯。你太棒了。还有什么我们没聊到但你想分享的吗？没有，我觉得我们已经聊了很多。我的意思是，还有别的，当我们开始聊起《办公室》时，我在想，并不是因为那是你们的剧集，但我真的、真心喜欢你们两人的婚礼。它们各自都有非常搞笑又感人的时刻，你知道的。
know. Well, I loved your wedding. We loved your wedding and we loved the storyline that Phyllis was ripping off Pam's wedding plans to Roy. For food, every... Yeah. And then Phyllis, you know, I've looked back, you know, at the photos of all of us in our wedding dresses and Angela Martin really just wears basically the same dress as Phyllis, almost.
嗯，我喜欢你的婚礼。我们喜欢你的婚礼，而且我们喜欢菲利斯抄袭帕姆对罗伊的婚礼计划这个故事线。关于食物，每个……是的。然后菲利斯，你知道的，我回看了一下我们所有人在婚礼上的照片，安吉拉·马丁基本上穿的和菲利斯的几乎是同一件婚纱。
It's true. What? Yeah. Mm-hmm. Very similar. Well, do, I think it would be great to do a side by side of each of our characters' wedding dresses. They were the three big weddings on the show.
确实如此。什么？是的。嗯哼。非常相似。好吧，我觉得把我们每个角色的婚纱照放在一起做个对比会很棒。那是剧中三场盛大的婚礼。
That's true. Because we actually didn't see Michael and Holly's wedding at all. Yeah, we didn't. Mm-hmm. But like when Jim cuts his tie off because you're, there's some things like, you know, like that. I do remember when Michael was dragging the wheelchair down the aisle? That was, we had to hear that clanging and banging coming down the aisle.
确实如此。因为我们根本没有看到迈克尔和霍莉的婚礼。是的，我们没有。嗯哼。但比如当吉姆剪断他的领带，因为你，有一些事情就像，你知道的，那种。我确实记得迈克尔把轮椅拖下过道的情景。我们不得不听着那种当啷作响的声音从过道传过来。
I also loved the scene where he tried to get in the wedding photos. Oh my gosh, there's more of it in deleted scenes on the DVDs, but like, I cannot believe that Michael was trying to get in your wedding photos, like in Phyllis's wedding photos. Wow. Yeah, you know, one of the things that Steve said, you know, back where we would get our hair and makeup done on stage there, were you around the day he said, you know, guys, I think this is going to be the best show we ever do. He said something to that effect. It was like around the first season, you know.
我也很喜欢他试图挤进婚礼合影的那个场景。哦天哪，DVD的删减片段里还有更多内容，但我简直不敢相信迈克尔试图挤进你的婚礼照片里，就像在菲利斯的婚礼照片里一样。哇。是的，你知道的，史蒂夫说过的一件事，你知道，在我们当时在片场做发型和化妆的时候，你记得他说的那个日子吗，他说，伙计们，我觉得这将是我们拍过的最棒的剧。他大致说了这样的话。那大概是在第一季左右，你知道的。
And I think he was right. Yeah, I do too. Yeah, pretty darn great. Yeah. Oh, Phyllis, we love you. We love you so much. It's so fun to see you. Yeah. I love you both so much, and I thank you for talking to me. Oh my gosh. Thank you. Well, I'm sorry, but if that interview didn't warm your heart, I don't know what to say. I just love her so much.
我想他是对的。是的，我也这么觉得。是的，相当棒。哦，菲利斯，我们爱你。我们太爱你了。见到你太高兴了。是的。我也非常爱你们俩，谢谢你们跟我聊天。哦天哪。谢谢。好吧，我很抱歉，如果那段采访没有温暖你的心，我不知道该说什么了。我太爱她了。
I think that would even make the Grinch's heart grow three sizes. Just listening to that interview with Phyllis. Phyllis, you're the best. Thank you so much for being on Office Ladies. And thank you all for listening. And don't forget to catch Phyllis in Inside Out 2 in theaters now. And we will be back next week with Moving On Part 1. See you then! See you then!
我觉得那甚至能让格林奇的心长三倍。只要听听对菲利斯的这段采访。菲利斯，你是最棒的。非常感谢你来到办公室女郎做客。也谢谢大家的收听。别忘了去影院观看菲利斯参演的《头脑特工队2》，目前正在热映中。我们下周将带着《前行（上集）》回归。到时候见！到时候见！
Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is produced by Earwulf, Jenna Fischer, and Angela Kinsey. Our senior producer is Cassie Jerkins. Our audio engineer is Jordan Duffy. And our associate producer is Ainsley Bubbaco. Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. ["Rubber Tree"] There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
感谢收听《办公室》女郎播客。《办公室》女郎由 Earwulf、珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金西联合制作。我们的资深制作人是卡西·杰金斯。我们的音频工程师是乔丹·达菲。我们的助理制作人是艾insley·布巴科。我们的主题曲是克里·布拉顿的《橡树》。["橡树"] 本集尚无评论。点击剧本中的任意句子即可发表评论。